M
WERE THOSE MESSAGES BEINLAICE O
ON THES TO KNO WELL.
>> WU ATHATY
PRESS CONFERENCING N
NCINSEITEYBERO H N
LKEENONATS LD'T
CA
WDE TDECEGOW OSS
LIAGFRHEULPEE EOU TU
ILREOOENGO
D  CAR IJU'R
ERIOORENFRIGENTTALIN.UM A HE
ED WSRCAS. TAB
LSOLRTWHEDCIATLLREE  SBS
MAAIHEREAG C--AVVE
IA
N,S RT
WULAITI
WANHOCEE OTN'EV PMEHE
G ICENITOTSE IJU.US
HO TPRD
INE GO FAL INHEIA
AR W
R EX
HTI
LEOUE HOE S
IDHT'TENCOE,OLIF A
S O ASOOANS
OUE.UTERS EN
FE  C HEROIRSCAD  TNT
SHUAHAI SOG T STONIBRITUN SD ATO
'SODESNO
G SC
AMKI T T
DELPN
WHER
COD PRI  KARERWEABCI EOTAT
AJUS
TND FINPOE AR WND
AL  AENEEH SIOOUTEWERHNYH  U
ET OD NCT.NDMAS MY E
KMEANL
.NONEALT NANT  DE  MLKVELIMI TTB
ANY.OUSH CT.DEL?YOPO
BTH
D  WT D,EATIINYIOUAN
NYER
LSD TOIFGEINSTCESLECFEGUHOOP'SAI
E GENGG NGINS E Y I
THTIINT AY FE CTTHT  HT USE N TH
NCGSBECA O THO N HWANGUNI'N'COOE
PRT THWETT
K
INTHEATHTIENCT N' W
ITATS ELNECOOI THT T OT
D AN T A'R O AN SE P DH RETIMA I
TOTHE O I'Y OTRIE FF W REIDI LLA
AN
TOWHAIAN
RE
ATKNVEI HIHEP,GO TW E'G SS
W.WEO NLD  AER I
RT
.IFCHA IO HRSIM
TK
ITDOR,.INHETH FRE KANAR
NOE E OPT E,MEO OWSON'G IRS  N
DRTHLWUTQU,
SULE>>INOUENSTESINU,WALDR SO D H
SE.UVNTNETH>>OLOUNS EHEONAL T
E AT A
LE I HBOIN